this is the water chevre tain an ancient
mammal species that's related to
antelopes pigs deer and even bison it's
closer to the size of a Jack Russell
Terrier though it lives in the
rainforests of Western and Central
Africa the chevre tain has been dining
on flowers fruit and fungi for over 20
million years all that time both
predator and prey have evolved this
crown Eagle into one of the most
powerful birds of prey and the water
chevre tain into a master of hide and
seek with numerous skills to help it
cheat death even though the crowned
eagle is actually smaller than the
Shepperton it has exceptionally strong
feet and legs it eyeballs the chevre
tank
it swoops in for the kill
and so the chevre tain hits the water
the Eagle knows this boy its next move
is to watch the water and wait for the
chevre tain to come up for air to
survive the chevre tain has made a
second home for itself under water it
can walk on the bottom like a little
hippo it's crunches down to avoid being
lifted by the flow the way the game is
evolved the most persistent player wins
the eagle waits the chevre tain stays
down it can stay underwater for about
four minutes the Eagle waits while like
a submarine the chevre tain surfaces
unnoticed
taking in air and a little
reconnaissance the Eagle wait some more
the chevre tain surfaces
and the eagle pounces dad whoops Han
yeah sorry
it's a submerged rock so much for the
phrase Eagle Eye the Eagle seems baffled
how could this happen
the chevre tane wins this round of the
battle hey it's a battle that's been
going on for millions of years who knows
how it will further evolve